they are images you won't see on
postcards from what is one of the most
beautiful of Aegean islands a hillside
in lesbos which many now call a jail
thousands of asylum seekers and migrants
waiting here while their claims to stay
are processed and every day more
arriving by the boatload a 3:00 a.m.
call and the crew of refugee rescue
scramble heading out to rendezvous with
a border vessel which has picked up
people from a dinghy in the sea Andrey
emerging from the darkness with the
first of more than 50 adults and
children on board this former RNLI
lifeboat is now doing important work in
Greece the crew all volunteers we are
here to help and we are here to like try
to feel any gap with like we feel that
exists and there's still people who are
willing to come here and volunteer for
this and help the boats name is matura
my friend in Irish and for a brief time
at least that's what these volunteers
want to be welcoming people who have
risked everything to get here but they
know the next stage for these Afghans
will be easy that's the heart of a
suspect definitely one of the hardest
aspects of our work knowing that Ivanov
ages reach Europe which should be
reaching safety it's just the start of
another very long an established process
and very hard situations from the port
the migrants will eventually be taken to
camps like Moria the largest on the
island where conditions are grim and
where volunteers and non-government
organizations are providing vital
assistance some like halliche Anza dean
who works in a tented overspill from
warrior know what living here is like he
came to greece himself as a syrian
refugee and now devotes his life to
trying to improve conditions for
thousands when I arrived here of course
it's not easy
it's difficult and hard but also you
have to be strong and you have to know
how to stand up for yourself and how to
find that way survive NGO say the Greek
authorities are not doing enough to help
asylum seekers and migrants some accused
the government of using the grim
conditions as a deterrent to others
that's certainly what Salaam Aldean
believes in 2015 he gave up his life in
business in Denmark to set up a
volunteer movement here helping families
there is no humanity
there is no humanity here and you know
without the volunteers the
organisation's on the island they
couldn't have survived that's for sure
so thanks for the all organisation on
the island and they will volunteers
these people had spilt somebody to help
them because the government doesn't help
many a critical of charities and
volunteers claiming they encouraged
migrants to come but there's no denying
the need here is overwhelming and the
loss of their work would impact
thousands Michele Clifford Sky News
lesbos Greece